foreign
kicks us off in Tulsa Oklahoma and
welcome to the Ramsay show
there happy New Year how are you all you
as well we're doing great how can we
help today
good good well I have two questions for
you so the first one is how to approach
my individual contributor role when I
really don't have a desire to move up
into management although I do value
recognition and achievement and then my
my second question is whether or not
it's a wise move to join the Air Force
Reserves or the Air National Guard
within the next year or two knowing that
the past two years have been full of a
lot of change and a lot of trauma for me
so it's kind of a two-fold question for
you all hey wow now we get some real
depth here so let's let's go for number
one first does that sound okay sure
that's great so the heart of your
question is what I heard what you said
Okay I want to grow or I want to be
recognized I love the way you put it you
want recognition uh but you don't want
to be promoted into a leadership
position am I understanding that that is
correct I love growing accounts and I
love earning more money and being wise
with that money but I don't necessarily
want to move into a management role
whereas my organization I'm at right now
is run by former Consultants who are
really demonstrating that up or out kind
of method of dealing with attrition and
I'm also getting some mixed messages
from my direct manager who very kindly
has said I'm the best person on the team
and she needs me so she can't promote me
so I'm getting some mixed messages and
what I really want to do is you know be
the best individual contributor I can be
and be wise with my money well it sounds
like totally what I want to do so it
sounds like to me the message that
matters is your director is your direct
leader and I would tell that leader hey
um this is a match made in heaven
because I don't want to lead I in fact I
get a little bit of of anxiety when I
hear that these consultants and our
leaders are kind of going up or out or
whatever I feel like I've gotten that
message but I gotta tell you I'm as
happy as I can be in the role that I'm
in
crushing it and I want to get well I
want to make more money and I want to
make the organization more money so I
make more money so I can manage my money
well I want to stay in this type of role
I'm happy to be your top performer
please protect me because I don't want
to be promoted into a leadership role
but this is what's weird about George uh
our Western Hemisphere
the way we we treat promotions it's like
well you gotta move up the ladder
instead of going what do you want to do
more of do you want to make more money
and do a little bit more of this you
know why does it always have to be I'm
going to pull you out of the seat where
you're crushing it
put you in a seat or you may not want to
be you may not want to lead people but
you might be the best salesperson so
they go well she needs to be over the
sales team and lead them so on your
misery yeah so I think the answer to
number one is
reaffirm what your leader is telling you
and going I'm as happy as can be protect
me and I want to stay here all I want to
do is is keep performing better get paid
more and spend that money wisely that's
that's what I think okay you got that
one I like that I like it love it thank
you now the the second one because I
want George to jump in on this
retirement thing but I've got to ask
George
um when you say you've been through a
lot of change and Trauma uh whatever
you're comfortable sharing I'm just
curious what that has been and how long
that's been going on
sure no I'm very happy to share and
there there's actually some great
changes in that but also some some
changes that were
um just a lot to deal with and heal with
so in the last two and a half years
excuse me um I I got sober I moved
across the country thank you thank you I
had a major surgery and a traumatic
divorce I lost over 110 pounds I changed
companies and I was finally diagnosed
and treated for ADHD so lots of great
things in there but also lots of things
that make me pause and say okay I want
to make sure that I'm making the right
decision because this would be like a 20
it didn't have to be a 20-year
commitment but I'm looking at a 20-year
commitment in the reserves or the guard
because it's important to me I want to
serve my country and do something so
beyond myself all right so that leads to
what I was really going to dive into and
let George talk about it as a retirement
option sounds like to me you want to
serve your country more than then you're
just trying to juice your retirement
benefits but that is kind of a benefit
pardon the uh the metaphor here is that
what I'm hearing I would say that's
correct because I couldn't even tell you
the dollar amount that those that
retirement would be it's much more about
serving my country
um also family lineage my grandfather
and my father both served and this is
really important to me would it stress
you out your current family relationship
life I know you're just recently
divorced I'm so sorry about that but
with this extra time
uh in serving our country
do you have margin for that to where
it's not a negative
would it affect other parts of your life
your job anything like that
No in fact uh at my job most of us have
served in some capacity I'm also single
and happily Child free
um so I don't view it I know I I don't
think it would I mean it would here's
the truth it would take away from my
yoga on the weekends that's what it
would take away from we can live with
that exactly
Namaste there you go mistake well then I
would do it and I would do it for the
only reason that you want to serve your
country and anything else is just an
auxiliary benefit that's a nice to have
but I would never do it for the
retirement benefits and it sounds like
based on what you told me your heart is
in the right place with this
um and I would pursue it if I were you
if that if that's what's uh where your
heart's saying to go then the retirement
benefit is just part of the package do
you have retirement as part of your
current job
I do I do um however I've worked at
startups for the last about eight years
or so
um however have had very steady
employment at startups but we all know
how startups go so that's always kind of
in the back of my head like I've got a
great retirement consistently putting 15
a year towards that but I do feel a
little bit behind I didn't really get my
first like grown-up job until the last
about eight years or so so a little bit
of it yeah there is part of me that
wants to make sure I'm playing catch up
but that's not the main motivator behind
this are you debt free
I am I'm debt-free I'm on baby step 3B
right now so soon you're going to be a
homeowner that's going to help you build
wealth what's your income yes sir uh 125
I make 125 000 a year oh I lost you are
going to retire with plenty of dignity
and plenty of time to enjoy as much yoga
as you can handle
you'll probably be teaching the class
but
honored to talk with you and and thank
you in advance for serving this great
country what a cool call lot to to
manage there can but she's very well
spoken and I if I was a hiring I'd hire
in yeah that's great and I think by the
way she said uh learned ADHD and she's
but there was a woman there that's
highly focused and she's live and just
rattling it off and I think the serving
is a great way to heal huge